prepare yourselves for some Advanced
language wordsmiths because it's time
for us to develop our vocabularies
that's right the word I'm focusing on in
this video is develop
devop it's a verb it means to grow
larger or more complex to build or
improve the noun form is development
which can mean how someone or something
grows or a building project now let's
develop our understanding of this word
by breaking it down into Parts the duh
part is just another form of the Latin
dis meaning not or away and velop comes
from a French word that means to wrap up
or to roll up but its Origins beyond
that are uncertain I love word Mysteries
like that so what this word means is the
opposite of rolling or wrapping
something up we're developing it we're
unrolling it imagine a map being
unrolled over a table or a suitcase
being unpacked so you can plan a trip or
choose an outfit you're expanding in
something in size unzipping the suitcase
stretching the map out to its fullest
extent that's what development literally
means but those are the pieces we have
du and velop can you think of words that
contain those word parts let's go 10
seconds music's
[Music]
on Welcome Back here are some words I
came up with the first two are very
similar there's envelop the verb which
means to roll or cover something up
right N means in envelop means to roll
so it's something that's been rolled up
in something else and then there's the
related noun envelope which some people
pronounce envelope which is a container
of some kind uh like a paper envelope or
envelope for sending a letter and with d
we have destabilize to make something
unstable not stable this can be literal
the stool's leg cracked destabilizing it
or it can be figurative the news that
Helen's mother had been a wizard this
whole time was psychologically
destabilizing those are words made up
from parts of develop in music the term
development refers to a part of the
piece where you explore variations on
your initial theme so let's get to the
development and use this word in a few
different sentences over many millions
of years sea slugs developed a wild
variety of natural defenses these
defenses are so wild y'all some of them
eat jellyfish and steal jellyfish
stinger cells to protect themselves with
what a strange technique to have evolved
or developed it has matured it's become
more advanced once they were defenseless
little sea slugs but now they have
jellyfish Stingers in their tentacles
okay let me use it figuratively um Jenna
developed her essay's argument over
numerous revisions she built it out she
made it better she's not literally
building something physical she's
developing ideas okay now let's see one
that uses the noun form of the word
develop
development the new mayor pursued a big
Housing Development on the site of the
old soda Factory a Housing Development
is when you turn something into housing
right here's this abandoned soda Factory
and now the mayor wants to redevelop it
wants to build something there to make
something new out of what had been there
previously I haven't wonder what it
would be like to live in an apartment
that used to be a Factory not too long
ago when I when I lived in Chicago there
was this Chocolate Factory that made all
of downtown smell like chocolate
brownies and I always wondered what it
would be like to live in that part of
the city let that idea develop in your
head what kind of factory would you most
want to live near or what kind of
factory would you most like to live
in well I think I've pretty well
developed your understanding of this
word you can learn anything daveid out